I wanted to get your thoughts on one new
story that sort of happened this week or
again that's coming out pretty soon
actually it's about two weeks Apple we
preview coverage is sort of dropped for
recently it's a quantum break you guys
are gonna quantum break yeah so remedies
next big game everyone loves on and wake
everyone big fans of max payne around
this office yeah yeah and this is like a
big game that originally when they were
pitching it was part of sort of
Microsoft's wider you know we're going
to have our television wing we're going
to have our video games wing we're going
to sort of cross pollinate the mawana so
they built this whole television show
featuring a bunch of very recognizable
actors and I plays were under embargo
for a lot of a but yesterday we streamed
the first like chapter of the game
essentially about 40 minutes of gameplay
followed by a 23 minute long cut line
cutscene oh snap yeah like well produced
not like cheap as chips like it'sit's no
house of cards but on the metal gear
solid as they could you know somewhere
touching himself is full of like you
know dozens of different characters and
side plots and whatnot and which is the
sort of that the latest in this long
legacy of video games trying to take
what happens in you know interactive art
and what happens in in film or
television and sort of merged the two of
them together right yeah am what do you
guys think about that is like a future
for video games did because you guys
work on the forefront of games
development with voice work and you also
have an eye for the theatrical side of
it which people most people in
development don't so what do you think
about that I think I think we're still
in we happen for a while we're in the
infancy of finding what works and what
doesn't in that you know and right now
we're still in that process to everyone
kind of throwing things at the wall and
seeing what sticks and I think because
we've had games that have really
elevated the platform from a
storytelling standpoint and bunted those
lines so well in recent years examples
being like Last of Us or a lot of the
telltale games where they can really you
know maintain an interactive element
throughout where you still feel invested
involved from an interactive standpoint
but still are enjoying and are engrossed
in the story in a way where you're
you're involved but still a viewer and
it's it's those are great examples and
in my opinion of that form developing
however with a lot of these renovations
and V are now promising even further
emerge
midi and and trying to make that
maintain that balance of atmosphere
interactivity without it being too heavy
one way the other I'm excited to see
these examples of games that are that
are make taking risks and trying out new
things and and when I when I heard the
whole the whole theme behind quantum
break what they're trying to do with
that I was really excited I'm still
really excited I'm always very curious
to see how that it turn out I'm a guy
who loves cutscenes I didn't skip
anything in middle years so I'm one of
the one of those guys even the truck oh
no I didn't I know I refers to watch it
all the way all the way where's this
truck goin something's gonna happen no
it's um I myself am actually very
excited about it I don't know if they'll
all work I find like we've had a lot of
David cages stuff will also tried a lot
of you know yeah interesting ideas that
often really hit the way you would hope
for but even so that sets a precedent
and is a great example for other game
designers to then build off of that and
make something that is more fine-tuned
towards what his no final vision may be
so in hits or failures they're all
helping build towards what will
eventually be the emerging platform of
interactive gaming and really the key
word that you said there was immersion
and I think we're seeing all media go
that way to immersion and like you said
you have to walk the line between not
being like oh this is work you know and
still feeling entertaining like you're
being told a story so you never want to
go like you know people give a lot of
[ __ ] to heavy rain right uh but they did
make a lot of progress a--'s and sure we
don't need to have to physically turn
every doorknob open every jar that's not
necessary but it is interesting the way
it's going but we're also seeing that
with digital comics right on iPads and
have a little sound effects or you know
little things with comics we're seeing
that even with twitch I feel like you
can still count that with twitch where
the audience can comment and participate
yeah while they're watching things so I
think anything that's going to start
merging the two yeah that's that's where
all medium is going in my in my opinion
what do you think when you see like hot
like front of camera recognizable actors
on something like want
break when you guys are like you're
already in there like you're part of
like video game performance right right
so like does it feel like they're sort
of coming into your into your
neighborhood and matt i mean i'm a big
proponent of the best performer for the
job right we should be what's considered
in some cases there been projects that
maybe you've worked on where they've
done the stunt casting route and will
bring somebody in without an audition
just because they like their work on a
project sometimes they're amazing and
they knock out of the park sometimes you
but mostly mostly i say but there are
situations where they'll go a week
recording or so and they'll be like
alright cool we're going to go ahead and
recast that right um still private
victory for us lets her know folks but
um but there are plenty of great
performers that can do both sides so I
you know I'm and I'm a big fan of a lot
of that work so like if the best perform
for the job steps into the ring go for
it you know that there is always that
worry that if if it goes more and more
celebrity talent than those of us who
don't have that kind of you know pool
hmm might be passed over in a lot of
situations for future roles where it
honestly in some cases it may not matter
if they're not using the likeness of the
actor performer it's about the
performance something actual individual
behind it yeah and so it depends on how
the projects being promoted and what
their marketing goals are for it is a
lot of those casting choices are a
marketing choice right and a little
project will get more marketing money if
they've got a name attached yet I mean
you can see that what quantum break then
you know there's a lot of very
recognizable people in that yeah Jen and
you can't fault them for that yeah and I
want to see a lot of them so do you
think that there's a different craft
though to like what they're doing in
terms of like I don't next to nothing
about performance at all but there seems
to be like there is a more maybe there's
like subtle nuance that exists obviously
in both forms but there when they're
acting in front of camera it's I don't
know I feel like the voice work it
requires a lot more energy or verbose
pneus or which might not necessarily
transition well for those individuals
whereas you guys are like comfortable
with yeah it's a different skill set
definitely and when it whether it comes
to voiceover behind the mic to
performance capture with facial capture
to on-camera acting each is its own
skill set that you're kind of switching
gears into with on
hammer everything is very very thrown
away very internalized minimize it's not
about showing your expressions it's
about keeping it all internal and very
subtle no you have the opportunity on
camera to display emotions through
subtle I've moments and through just you
know reactionary very very minut
expression changes you don't have that
opportunity behind the microphone and
you have to be able to convey those same
subtle shifts and changes with only your
voice and that is why you'll get some
actors who aren't trained classically or
3 at wrigley other theatrically who then
get behind the mic and then it sounds
very stilted and right in monotone
because they're used to relying on that
one skill set when they haven't learned
the other conversely you have some voice
actors that move over to on-camera work
and are way too over the top right so
you find performers who have trained in
all those different skill sets know how
to switch those gears and can really
knock out of the park both ways and a
lot of on-camera actors that come over
and the performance capture and voice
over and do a great job you'll find are
those that a lot of cases are trained
theatrically on stage because that skill
set lends itself very well both ways
like both projecting yourself and also
having sort of like small mmm tender
moments yeah and knowing how to arrange
and kind of you know meticulously
puppeteer those right uh would you like
as you know folks you do this
professionally would you like video
games to go down the route of what
quantum break is doing and actually
having that live-action element is that
something that excites he or did is that
something that maybe you think actually
detracts from the work that you do oh no
I take it or leave it yeah I will have
to see it I I mean if all video games
start to go that route then that could
be unfortunate but um I mean I i love
dungeons and dragons and i also love
fall out you know I in those two things
offer they say she ate me in different
ways yeah and I think that's probably
what we'll see this stuff like quantum
break I don't think it's going to be a
replacement I also am a bit of a sucker
for the artistry of digitally painting
environments and and the the artistry
that the CG artists go into with video
games I don't think it's going to be
universal though I mean [ __ ] will still
see
games like nidhogg come out which are
8-bit which are is a phenomenal game it
just satiates different needs yeah yeah
and on that point to a the interactive
element of gaming can only allow so much
live action pre filmed content before
it's no longer as interactive as the
driver requires to be called interactive
so they'll always be a line that they
can push to a certain point before you
have to then turn it over and rely on
all the wonderfully talented 3d
animators and riggers and and people
that actually create all these variables
that allow the interactive experience so
I'm it doesn't worry me by any means I'm
curious to see how it's involved and how
it can help elevate the storytelling
platform of games but I don't foresee it
taking over or replacing yeah you know
other elements just just because the
limitations of the the pre filmed you
know video format yeah otherwise we end
up with a whole new realm of 3d oh yeah
yeah Josh Radnor's you know happens all
over again exactly let's get that night
raf 2017 and we imagination kick-started
guys it's time like it thanks so much
for talking about that if you're
watching this on demand you have any
thoughts yourself about the future of
3do games coming back let us know what
you think in the comment box below
you